[Música]
muy buenos días a todos y todos yo soy
jennifer y siempre ha sido una niña muy
extrovertida y también muy curiosa
resulta que cuando yo tenía cuatro años
tenía que caminar al trabajo con mi mamá
y cuando pasábamos por el centro de
nuestra comunidad
yo le preguntaba que decía en cada uno
de los rótulos que veía
ante esto mi mamá describió en un cartón
todas las sílabas para que yo aprendiera
a leer en ese momento mi mamá estaba
sembrando en tierra fértil y yo estaba
conociendo al mi primer maestro de la
vida
cuando estaba en primer grado yo iba a
una escuela de la tos de sí pero mi mamá
consiguió un trabajo y entonces me tuve
que cambiar de escuela algunos de los
vecinos dijeron que probablemente yo
perdería el año por la escuela donde
venía sin embargo yo estaba entusiasmada
porque finalmente podría aprender inglés
y aprender a usar una computadora el
momento de aprender de mis papás y el
mío fue diferente porque cuando yo
aprendí a usar una computadora tenía 8 y
mis papás tuvieron el acceso a esa
tecnología hasta los 30 pero eso no
importa porque quien dice que le importa
a la hora de aprender algo nuevo lo que
importa es que estemos listos para
recibir esas semillitas de aprendizaje
cuando yo estaba en noveno fui a una
gira la usr y ahí escuché hablar del
sistema de colegios científicos de costa
rica cuando llegué a mi casa busqué en
internet para ver más información y en
medio de los diez mejores colegios del
país encontré un hombre diferente que
llamó mi atención en el momento entonces
cuando yo leí la descripción supe que
ahí pertenecía así que aplicar
a pesar de que la gente me decía que hay
nada más entraba a la gente inteligente
pero era más que inteligencia era
esfuerzo y pasión
porque quién iba a imaginar de que en
una gira la ugr yo iba a encontrar el
colegio humanístico costarricense a mí
nadie me dijo que eso existía yo lo
encontré
considero que debemos ser conscientes de
nuestros sueños y de lo que nos apasiona
porque nosotros somos los responsables
de extasiar esa sed por aprender algo
más pero eso conlleva mucho trabajo para
mí estudiar en el humanístico y mudarme
a la ciudad con 16 años
represento muchas cosas frustraciones
llorar en el bus aguantará hambre hay
veces y muchas cosas más pero eso no
importa porque lo que más importaba era
la meta y usted no sabe lo rico que se
siente o probablemente si saben cuando
uno se gana algo con su propio sudor los
aprendizajes que yo conseguí por esa
experiencia fueron más allá de la parte
académica fue aprender a ser una persona
independiente y también crítica de todo
lo que me rodeaba y eso me llevó a mi
siguiente escalón porque así como un día
se abre una puerta y yo en contra el
humanístico otro día se abre otra puerta
y yo encontré la red la r es una escuela
de agricultura
yo consideré que en ese lugar yo podía
encontrar todas las herramientas para
poder cambiar mi comunidad para bien sin
embargo para entrar a la red no era
solamente que me aceptaran yo tenía que
conseguir una beca hay alguien que dijo
la gente en ese momento es solamente
para gente que tiene dinero pero yo
aplique y me gané una beca en la agencia
encontrado mi lugar feliz pero eso no ha
significado que no haya tenido ningún
problema porque también he encontrado
muchos retos y he tenido altibajos de
emociones sin embargo todos esos
espacios en los que yo he estado me han
permitido desarrollar mi potencial al
máximo y desarrollar capacidades como
hablar en público relacionarme con
personas de diferentes partes poder
enseñarle a los demás poder ser
creativos y principalmente poder
trabajar con las comunidades en el
título que yo recibiré probablemente no
se van a reflejar todo esto que me hace
a mí ser una persona porque son estas
habilidades las que a mí me diferencian
de los demás
todos estos espacios en los que yo
estuve me hicieron a mí ser consciente
de algo que yo necesitaba trabajar
positivamente en la sociedad y resulta
que la experiencia se vivió el año
pasado cuando estuve trabajando con
comunidades rurales de panamá
en estas comunidades yo trabajé en el
fortalecimiento del intercambio de
semillas cuando mis productores me
recibieron se mostraron tímidos con su
conocimiento al saber de que yo estaba
en la universidad y que era extranjera
en ese momento yo encontré mi primera
tarea
tenía que crear una horizontalidad entre
nosotros para que la información pudiese
fluir en ambas direcciones y adivinen
qué hice les conté de dónde venía y
encontré cosas en común con ellos de esa
manera ellos me sintieron parte de su
comunidad
el contexto en el que yo me desarrollé
fue con productores que tenían que eran
muy humildes y que tenían la mayoría
mucha mayor edad que yo eran señores y
señoras de edad avanzada entonces además
del reto que tenía por el diferente
contexto social yo era una jovencita
trabajando con señores entonces cargaba
con el estereotipo de que por nuestra
diferencia de edad no íbamos a poder
trabajar con éxito en equipo entonces
apareció mi segunda tarea por hacer yo
debía de colocarme como aprendiz y eso
significaba un reto porque debía estar
en silencio y a mí me encanta estar
hablando pero en ese momento yo me senté
como ven en la foto ahí con don adriano
con papel y lápiz de escuchar todo lo
que ellos tenían que decir y mientras yo
escuchaba me sentía como una bajita
polinizadora porque toda esa información
que ayuda a recaudar la iba a poder
llevar donde otros productores y ellos
podrían tener frutos nuevos
en el contexto en el cual ellos estaban
se presentaron un montón de vicisitudes
porque resulta que algunos de ellos no
sabían leer y escribir y algunos otros
no tenían acceso a luz o agua potable
entonces encontré mi tercera tarea yo
debía de ser creativa pues a cada uno de
mis productores yo debía de enseñarles
de manera diferente entonces como ven
con la señora belkis ellos me llevaron a
sus fincas y mientras estábamos viendo
en las plantaciones me contaban
historias de su cultivo y también de
tradiciones ancestrales que ellos tenían
entonces yo pensé cómo podemos hacer
para enseñarles a estos productores hay
veces en nuestro día a día nos olvidamos
de imaginar porque ya nos creemos
grandes pero en este trabajo que yo tuve
la imaginación fue mi herramienta
principal así que con los productores
que sabían leer pintamos los libros y
con los que no sabían leer entonces
hicimos dibujos y con los que no tenían
acceso a la luz entonces utilizamos el
sol
la verdad fue una experiencia muy
enriquecedora al momento en que ellos
estuvieron en conjunto con la comunidad
y ellos estaban empoderados del
conocimiento que tenían y empezaron a
convencer a unos y a otros de cuáles
eran las herramientas que ellos
utilizaban yo considero de todo este
aprendizaje que tuve en esas tres
situaciones en las que estuve de que el
trabajo que tenemos que hacer con
nosotros mismos al reconocer cuál es la
el gran conocimiento que tenemos es uno
de los más importantes y fue la mayor
lección que yo aprendí con mis
productores porque al fortalecer que su
conocimiento valía ellos entendieron que
todas las personas que estábamos a su
alrededor lo necesitábamos y es un
trabajo que tenemos que hacer con
nosotros mismos como resultado que tuve
que don feliciano uno de mis productores
me contó los secretos para poder
conservar su semilla y la señora américa
que está acá ella dejó de cortar las
flores de su arte y empezó a polinizar
los porque finalmente entendió cuál era
ese concepto a través de mis charlas
no importa lo que hagamos en nuestra
vida para hacer un camino significativo
en ella lo que importa es la actitud que
tengamos frente a estos retos
como el resultado
tuvimos una red de distribución de
semillas allá en panamá y ante el éxito
de esto tuve la oportunidad de replicar
los con una comunidad del caribe
costarricense y entonces a ellos también
les enseñé de semillas déjenme mostrar
la foto ahí está de esa manera yo
aprendí a cambiar mi país
ahora les quiero contar de que todo esto
que hace que me mueve ha hecho que yo
tenga tres frutos en este año en junio
tuve la oportunidad de volver a ver a
mis productores en el encuentro nacional
de agricultura orgánica y presentarles
con fotos y con resultados cuál era lo
que habíamos logrado durante nuestro
trabajo juntos y en julio tuve la
oportunidad de viajar a ruanda donde
conocí a clarín quien hizo este vestido
y ahí también pude compartir mi
experiencia y pude representar a los
becados mastercard que estudiamos en la
red
y dentro de unos días estaré viajando
alemania para también compartir los
resultados que tuve con este trabajo en
la distribución de semillas
quién se iba a imaginar que la hija de
lidia y santiago iba a estar hoy aquí
para contarles todas las oportunidades
que he tenido y todos los logros que se
han presentado en mi vida
mi contexto no era el más favorable la
verdad no se esperaba mucho de mí pero
ha sido gracias a mucho trabajo y a la
ayuda de muchas personas que yo puede
estar hoy aquí compartiendo con ustedes
para terminar a mí me gustaría contarles
cuáles son las tres cosas que deben de
saber para poder caminar en esta vida y
ser suelo y se me uno cuando somos
suelos debemos estar dispuestos a ser
parte de una comunidad y sentirnos uno
con nuestro maestro dos cuando somos
semilla debemos estar conscientes de que
somos la semilla más importante de todas
y debemos hacer sentir a las personas
que están a nuestro alrededor de que
también son semillas importantes para
que podamos aprender unos de otros y 3
debemos de estar conscientes de que en
cada paso que nosotros demos en la vida
podemos ser suelo o semilla es decir
maestros o aprendices sin importar
nuestra edad nuestra procedencia nuestro
género muchas gracias
[Aplausos]